Sam do you have the coronavirus I was
not able to get tested but it appears so
based off of just symptoms from out now
according to my doctor so who the [__]
knows but you were saying so far kind of
mild today's a little worse it today for
sure the wait okay so you know how
everyone says it's like not that bad or
bad that's hard to quantify so the way
that I've been quantifying it is when I
stay home from work today if this was
last June right and yesterday was the
first day that I would have stayed home
and just barely today for sure I would
stay home from work I see so no it's not
that bad but dude shortness of breath is
scary because like a it's not bad right
like I can breathe perfectly fine but it
definitely is like oh my god what
happens if this gets any worse right and
I was Gary I've been following a bunch
of people who are like pretty fit like
there's one guy who's an Olympic athlete
and he's a I think he's a swimmer or
runner Australian swimmer a runner he
has it and he's like yeah so yeah mate
was tough and he's like you know
shortness of breath and I just you know
it's impossible to train like this and
you know he's talking about it and then
somebody like retweeted it and they're
like this guy's an Olympic athlete by
the way like and he was basically yeah
this gets tough and then there's the guy
another guy followed who's healthy guy
he was the bachelor his name's Colton
and he got it and he's like you know
pretty jacked guy he was an NFL player
for a bit and he's like he does a little
Instagram post to like update his fans
of a holiday it's bad yeah he's like you
look at I mean looks raggedy as hell
like he is not he is getting knocked out
by this thing and it's been like a week
plus and he's doing just at home
treatment and he's like quarantined in a
room his you know girlfriend and their
family they just deliver meals to the
door he kind of opens the door drags it
in
I haven't left the home and about a week
like on Saturday I went for a walk but
besides that or since Saturday I haven't
gone on a walk I haven't left house at
all
Wow it's you know it's crazy so do you
know how like you here like Ti and
Martha Stewart and dr. dre all served
house arrest and their their house
arrests are definitely different because
their homes are massive right but only
in it but house arrest would suck still
like it would be that cool right it's a
little bit of an arrest yeah it's crazy
okay well I hope your symptoms are mild
I hope it's just actually the cold
because I think it's fine we'll see I
mean whatever it's all the same right
right all right well the show must go on
so what do we want to talk about today
so first you guys released this like
book thing what is that I saw that
yesterday it's just to get more sales to
trends it's to get people in the door
and it's incredibly effective what we
did was we put together all of our the
best talks with Iran we transcribed them
and when I first started the company do
you remember this book called the
founders at work by Jessica yeah look
like changed my frickin life and it's
not even up I mean it's a book
technically but like she didn't do any
like work other than what you and I do
every week right
and she just transcribed her interviews
and so I was like let's do that so we
did and so it's pretty cool yeah I
downloaded it and I started to skim
through it I was reading the Pandora
guys one and said that's good okay where
do people get it if they're listening to
this they want that good question I want
to see we just posted it we just posted
it Tuesday so let me see if it even
ranks on Google listen we'll put a link
to it in the description if you want to
read this thing it's is it free or you
have to you have to become a dollar
that's a dollar dollar and though
everyone's like what's the catch I'm
like well it's a dollar and then you're
gonna be automatically subscribed to
trends but you have two weeks to cancel
so get value or sign up and try it and
if you don't like it then just cancel
and you're only
a dollar right the so if you go to
trends that Co you should you'll see it
at the top like a like a link it's not
even ranking for Google yet and
hopefully we can link to it in here okay
cool
we'll do that that's fun that's exciting
I'm glad you guys did that yeah it's
great
the cold email lecture one was even
better I mean that was people love that
[__] yeah okay cool so we wanted to we
did a bunch of the YC companies last
week or last week a couple days ago and
reaction was good people wanted more we
only did five or six of them at that
time the way I'm thinking about this is
like I listened to a couple of sports
podcast like Bill Sam it's podcast and
every year around like the NFL Draft
it's like there's these special sort of
annual events that you do like these
deep dives for and to me that's kind of
what the YC demo day is it's like I
could see us doing this as a recurring
thing in the podcast where it's like oh
that's our version of the NFL Draft you
see all these hot prospects and you're
scouting them and you're checking them
out and you're you're using them to sort
of see what are the you know what are
the smartest people working on where do
they see the opportunities and then what
do we think about those what did yours
write in this day because I talked to
Jack and a couple other guys about this
and they go I think the some of them are
like I think that Bash was pretty weak
and I totally disagree I think there's a
bunch of amazing things so people who
have been going to YC demo day for years
this is like their favorite thing to say
it's like oh yeah YC bash this year's
week and like you know I don't know to
what extent that's true versus just a
cool thing to say you sound cool by
saying it I'm always skeptical of those
Jack's not the type to do that though so
he said he was not like totally negative
but he was basically like is okay so
what I heard from what I heard the
sentiment I got from people who've been
going to demo day for a while is you
know in the past it was like the glory
days and there was less competition on
the Investor side and the companies were
better and higher quality and there was
fewer of them so you could go deeper
with them one of the problems now is
like for example demo day has become
something where they get up on stage
they talk for I think one minute they do
a one-minute presentation
and then it's like if you're interested
you know come talk to me and then
there's a line of investors already
wanting to talk to that person from the
one minute pitch and it's so competitive
the deals or do half the deals are done
before demo day just because people
swoop in beforehand and then the other
half get done you know very shortly
afterwards so a lot of smart people are
like dude this is a frenzy that is not
smart now it is but if I'm doing it in 1
minute pitch it's just a slide one slide
and to two paragraphs and then you
decided to talk to them more or not and
I think that's great to be honest if I
was an operator which I am like I see
these and I'm like oh my god for my
founders it's fantastic
well I'm like I should do that and even
for the investors I actually think this
one's better because it's digital so
it's like you say it's like tinder you
basically when you see the listing you
say yes I'm interested in no I'm not
and if you if you say yes then they get
a request that says this person wants to
talk to you and then they can say yes
and then it matches and so I think
that's actually better this year because
because it's digital I think people are
gonna take time to have conversations
whereas when it's sort of a live event
you it's again it's just like a meat
market you're just sort of it's like you
know the old Wall Street trading floor
people just standing up and yelling [__]
it's a little bit faster paced and
people don't feel like they're able to
make thorough decisions and what's in
well I think what we I don't know if we
told us to people I don't know we want
have to blank this out we won't name
names but people can't see what you and
I see so we're writing off like a
private list and I don't think we're
breaking any of the rules I mean it's
not like yeah I don't think so
TechCrunch has reported on all these
companies now and also there's some
companies that say off the record and we
just won't talk about this no problem
do you what can I do wait did yesterday
I was pretty hopped up on dayquil the
other day did we talk about did we talk
about this so here's a theme that I
noticed I we talked about last time
about how there's like X of India so
right now I see Bill calm of India right
this thing for lat this thing's for
Latin America export for Africa yeah ok
so we saw that a lot we saw that a lot
and I like you
that day India thing last time I went
back and looked there's two like 28
companies in the batch that are Indian
startups like the India we took over the
spelling bee and now we're taking over
YC yeah let's go it on no at first I was
like I don't know if I like that not the
country thing but like we're just gonna
wear this wear this business but of that
region right and I think I've changed my
opinion I think it's cool because why
comment you're supposed to be all about
innovation and [__] and it's not exactly
innovative to say you're gonna be the
smile direct Club of Latin America but I
still think it's cool and that's what I
want to bring up did you did we did we
talk about that we didn't talk about
that one now did you read that I didn't
look into it but yeah we can talk about
it okay so what was it called
they don't how do I do a search on here
but anyway the the it was called um you
see I can't do it they're not letting me
do a ctrl F okay it was called moons
okay it's and they just say smile direct
Club but for Latin America and here's
why I like this and one of their decks
they go smile direct Club became a
billion dollar company in five years
we're gonna do it in four and and I
looked up the people behind it and the
people behind it previously worked at
rocket internet which is notorious for
cloning companies model in different in
different industries or cloning on
buffered Thailand or something and I'll
uh I mean there's pros and cons to that
but it definitely creates some value and
the fact that they said that at Y
commenter I think is like I just think
they're ballsy and I love these guys
yeah so there's a bunch of these Augusto
for Africa acorns for India cameo for
India flex port for Africa smile direct
Club for Latin rightly this is a you
know it's not like a groundbreaking idea
but it's it's you it really does stand
out when you look at the list I want to
do the opposite I want someone to tell
me what school in India that's not in
America so I'm doing that so I'm
basically putting together a report of
the coolest companies in India that
don't have analogs here like for example
just company called Bijou have you ever
heard of Bijou byj you and ey Ju yeah
this guy basically started off as a
teacher and he would teach like
essentially test prep oh you freaking
love this I think I've told you about
this before but basically yeah you like
you say that's your dream yeah this this
guy he started off as a small teacher in
a town basically and was doing test prep
and then sort of got bigger and bigger
and bigger people wanted to learn from
him to the point where he was selling
out stadiums of people coming to watch
him teach math and that was when I saw
the picture of the stadium I thought
this is that's remarkable
then he turned it into an online
learning platform a basically a video
based teaching platform sort of like
Khan Academy but for profit and it's
eight billion dollar company now and
this guy Bijou is sort of one of the
youngest billionaires in India he's a
t-shirt but turned billionaire which is
very rare and you know cool product cool
company and there's actually a company
in this YC batch that's trying that's
the former first instructor of Bijou
he's like I was the face of Bijou
because he was in all the videos and he
left to start his own thing he's like
you know here's the dirty secret about
Bee Gees thing it has very low retention
great at making money great to getting
people to sign up but less than 15% of
people stick with the course as he goes
along
we're doing this other way and we're
gonna win and they're in this batch as
well so that's interesting so I would
love to ask you questions about that
first I want to tell you that I'm
looking at their Wikipedia it says they
do they're worth eight billion dollars
they do 80 million in US dollars in
sales and then it says they only have
five employees yeah that's wrong and
also they do more they do more revenue
recently there were over a hundred
million I think the last like I've read
something where they were or they were
doing over a hundred million but so why
in a way they have five in place that'd
be amazing why is this big in India but
not America is because Indians love math
and science I mean yes education is like
you know God in India like you you can
be dirt poor in a village but you'll do
anything to educate your kids and you
know even these or any people in America
you probably notice or like you know
their parents are pretty strict about
education you got to get good grades all
that stuff
and so Indians are willing to pay
anything for education and they don't
really pay anything for anything else so
you know entertainment is is usually
lower on the list
although Bollywood does well but like on
a per capita basis where you're gonna
spend your money education is sort of
number one for for Indians so that's the
first part second part is they have such
a huge population so you can take a
really small amount of money from such a
huge number of people and built a very
big company that's the second part how
much bigger is India than America and
population three times yes at four times
I think it's at one pole I think it's I
think it's over 1 billion and us 300
million I believe so it'd be like about
4 times and and of course not all those
people have smartphones not all those
people have money but like you know it's
correct it's India has like sort of the
largest growing middle class so that's
some of the reason why this works is
because people willing to pay for
education and there's so many people
that if you take a few bucks from each
and everybody's willing to pay for this
because it's education that adds up but
you know 8 billion is sort of out it it
is outpacing the revenue growth right so
I think the part of it is the story of
what this becomes and there are sort of
defensibility
that's probably why they're valued so
much higher than they're valid then
their revenue would suggest do you think
that that that can be popular in America
oh I think so like I think Khan Academy
is fairly popular and it's mostly in
America no money though it's just yeah
it's a non profit and they don't pour
money into growth like these guys do I'm
sure these guys are aggressively trying
to grow and using their payback to to
sort of fund more growth but yeah I do
think like something like this can work
here but you know we'll see there might
be other reasons why it doesn't there's
a whole bunch of other companies I
basically found these five guys on
Twitter who are like in the Indian
startups thing that are actually really
smart and once I started following them
I started seeing awesome companies all
the time and I'm trying to put together
essentially the Mary Meeker internet
trends report that she does every year
for like global internet trends I'm
doing that just at India State of the
State of the Union Indian startup scene
here's what you need to know because a
lot of people in America want to know
but they're not gonna do the research to
figure out what's going on in the India
Tec seemed and I think I can distill it
down I am and probably gonna steal that
that is a great okay great what did you
cut that was cool like a trends report
of mary meeker for different countries
yeah mary meeker for india basically can
I tell you why I think that's a great
idea is because have I told you about
Kevin Ryan he's in charge that media
company right so Kevin Ryan was the 20th
employee at double-click and
double-click ended up becoming a Adsense
or Adwords and Google bought it for
three or four billion dollars very
successful and then so he was the CEO
he's the 20th employee and then CEO so
he was successful in that regard then
with his earnings he made told me that
he made twenty million dollars
personally with his earnings he went and
started this thing called Silicon Alley
group in Silicon Alley group created
MongoDB which is now a publicly traded
company in the billions of dollars they
created Business Insider they created
about Zola which is big and they created
about four other things and one of the
things that they did was they create a
guilt guilt group which is like flash
deals for women's clothing and the
reason he started it was he said because
I called email them and asked him all
these questions that became friends with
him and he told me that he was walking
down the street in Paris and saw a long
line outside of a women's store and he
asked a woman like what is this thing
and they go Ellie do they do these deals
every day only for an hour at noon and
so they're starting to do them online
but they still do them in person and he
goes oh oh I'm gonna do that in America
and that's how guilt started nice yeah
so you're basing import these sort of
the behaviors and innovations you see in
foreign markets back into the US not
just right now US an exporter of
innovation and it's a thing we can also
become an importer of innovation yeah I
mean like you did it and you kind of you
try to do it with sushi trains yeah yeah
when we did their sushi thing yeah like
in Australia that was a common and in
the US
and I don't think it still has caught on
but you you did the same thing well we
tried you you definitely tried it was a
good swing I think it's a great swing
and in case you're curious I just looked
it up while we were talking Khan Academy
because it's a nonprofit they all their
financials are available and they do
like 80 million dollars in sales yeah so
actually on par with Bijou and does the
same real quick where you're at how many
students they have that active like
active learners anything it does so if
you go to con a con con Academy annual
report org you can see all the
information okay I'm gonna check that
out afterwards and I'm gonna do a report
on them because I'm a education nerd and
so I'm gonna like I'm gonna bring them
to the table for the next podcast all
right so let's let's go back into the YC
companies let's just trade off you do
one that you find interesting I'll do
one that I find interesting go for it I
did smile direct Club for Latin America
you're my turn alright so I'm gonna do
this one I don't know exactly how you
say YZ wholesale or love it wholesale I
love this train that up yeah really
interesting company so basically the
premise is it's a marketplace for buying
and selling used smartphones and you
know I'll tell you some of their stats I
haven't sort of verified how real these
are but they say that you smartphone
sales are 46 billion dollars a year
annual market they say that 230 million
smartphones are sold per year you could
do the math that checks out they have so
what they did is they made a marketplace
where you could if you have phones and
you're a wholesaler you can basically
say hey I'm either I'm looking to buy or
looking to sell and they made it like a
stock market you basically put a a bid
up you say I'd like to buy this iPhone
and if somebody has it they can fill
your order and they can basically like
dude they can close your transaction out
there your ticket out or you can say I'm
selling a hundred of these specific
Android phones and somebody could say
I'll buy ten of those and so they made
it easy they said that most of this used
to happen through Facebook groups
whatsapp sort of the underground you
know just using social tools but they I
wasn't a marketplace and that was
focused on this and so they they've
400,000 and gmv so far now DMV
you know you can assume maybe they're
making in the tens of thousand dollars
themself then the GMB gross merchandise
volume volume okay so basically how much
is total sold through their market so if
one sells for a thousand dollars that's
$1,000 of gmv their cut might be 5% 10%
of that but this is a because the
smartphone if the smartphone if the used
smartphone marketplace is this big and
they have some stats about how fast it's
growing they say that you smartphone
sales is growing faster than new
smartphone sales per year because you
know Apple is trying to like make the
old model irrelevant so quickly and sure
some people do upgrade but there's all
these other phones still out there that
are still very good phones I like I I
can afford new phones I up until my most
recent phone all of them have been used
and the the best part about these guys
is so I believe that they were bootstrap
time members not sure but they so
they've gotten to this point they they
themselves were former buyers and
traders of cell phones and they had sold
prior to this just as brokers eight
million dollars over the cellphones and
then decided to create a sort of
technology marketplace out of this so if
you think about it market love it style
of business marketplace love it so I
love that love that they're going for
use market use smartphones I love that
they're doing a marketplace I love that
they came from a background where they
actually did this manually before and
we're sort of prolific brokers eight
plus plus love this love this company
here on this YC list okay I like it let
me play devil's advocate here which is
okay so I looked up a few okay so first
of all I think that it this is a lot
harder than people think the reason why
I think it's a lot harder is I think
it's incredibly competitive with a lot
of people who are already very
established so I think giving
distribution and getting eyeballs on
their product is going to be
prohibitively expensive maybe I also
think that so there's a company called
swap do you know swap ah no but I see
your note here
okay here's why this is interesting I've
actually used it before but I didn't but
what's interesting is I posted or I have
a thread that I found of the guy who's
so swap ax is the same thing
slightly different I don't know how it's
slightly different but it's the same
it's a you were you by youself
cellphones what's interesting is that in
2011 the guy who started swap up posted
on Hacker News and he said hey I'm
launching this thing on the side here's
what it does and so you can actually go
and like see how he started it and it's
I don't know how big it is right now but
it's it comes up number one when you
google by you cell phone so I would
imagine it does I bet you it does fifty
million dollars in sales at least
because I'm comparing it to the person
that's number two which is gazelle which
is a big company but anyway swap
bootstraps and so I if I was a greedy if
I was these these guys how you say easy
yeah if I was these ease guys and I or
what did you say let's go with easy if I
was easy I would be greedy and want to
raise very little money like less than a
million dollars and just see how well
how I can just make this really
profitable but you know they say launch
three months ago 400 kg MV monthly 8%
margin profitable and growing a twenty
percent month-over-month of course easy
to be profitable when you have two
people and you're not taking salaries
but nonetheless I think this could be a
profitable business because of the you
know the sort of take rate and here's
why I but here's why I don't know if I
would raise money if I was these guys is
heavy did you see what happened two days
ago do you know this up and let go I
know some something bad happen offer up
and let go combined Oh interesting
okay they merged who was the sort of
bigger parent was it offer up yep offer
up was the bigger parent and they raised
an additional 120 million dollars to
make this all work and so that's not a
good sign and you know they have a
pretty cool story I don't know if you
guys told it or where I read this but
offer up has a pretty cool story where
it sort of started I believe on my
butcher this might be thinking of
something else but I believe it was
there in Canada
and people have these buy sell trade
groups on Facebook and they saw this
behavior of Facebook you know sort of
local used goods selling happening and
then they started they built off the
back of that of these Facebook groups
for buying new stuff and they built
offer up off that of that that community
of people so I I i dig that they also
raised like five hundred million dollars
and they haven't hit terminal velocity I
mean they're not like they're not a
player yet compared to eBay and
Craigslist so I would say if I was these
guys if I was ease easy or ease I would
um I would be very happy to start and
own that if I was an investor which I am
and I just came across these guys I
think I would invest a small amount of
money because I think I could make money
off of it but I don't know if I would
raise venture capital like significant
amount yeah I think they still need to
prove a lot yeah for sure I think it's a
good investment I like him alright let's
go to the next one okay let's do um
build a plane love this
if these this is a this could
potentially it could be a ten billion
dollar company I think tell me why okay
so build a plane what so what they do is
they look at it's boring let me see I'll
try to read the exact description but
what they do is they it's project
management for construction okay though
let's find it build a plane but here's
why I think it's cool first of all
there's member hi I was just gonna read
their description since people have done
more contacts so we're a powerful
dashboard for construction companies we
give them visibility and control of
project finances change management
documents compliance at communication
blah blah blah they built a different
company that got acquired for 80 million
prior to this and they say bill plant us
all via the core issues of being the
centerpiece of projects empowering full
automation blah blah blah okay whatever
basically they're saying that
total profit they're saying that
construction costs controlling
construction costs and and making them
more efficient represents a sort of a
ten billion dollar opportunity globally
here's some of our features here's our
product check it out so when you're
building a 300 unit apartment building
and you want to see how much everything
costs you want to see RFPs for your
vendors and you want to know what your
cash flow Gleave what your cash output
is simple right yeah I think there's the
the this is one of those where if you
win you're in such a big space that your
your prize is humongous
hard for two reasons hard to get any
sort of blue-collar project industry to
adopt software is always a challenge
when you do it it looks like oh yeah
obviously they used to be using paper
and pen or they used to just use
clipboards and you know whatever and now
and it looks obvious in retrospect but
there's also that so many cases where
it's like yeah we just our thing is
better it would have saved them time and
money they just didn't put it in their
workflow so that's one piece on the
other side I think there's a lot of
competition I know there's like several
companies that are you know every year
there's like 15 companies that try to do
project management software for
construction and the question is what do
these guys know that they that the
others don't
or what is their unique angle that
didn't come through for me in this page
it did not come through to me either
but just because the market is so big if
I was these guys this is one of the few
companies where I'd be like get as much
cash as you can right out the gate and
just throw it at the wall and go big or
go bankrupt why why do you advocate for
that because it just what do you think
the cash does for them why do they need
so much cash I would hire just say math
okay so there's a few ways that you can
grow you can grow through content
marketing you can grow through word of
mouth which happens way less people
think you can grow through like network
effects like Facebook you can grow
through paid advertising which is really
easy if your product is achieved or you
can go grow through hiring a sales team
right I love products that are priced in
such a way where you can afford to hire
a sales team you cannot
Ford to hire a sales team if your
product is probably less than 10 grand a
year and so what I would do is I would
create a fat office in Dallas a huge
office in like Charlotte and then maybe
in office and or like like Nashville and
Dallas and then like maybe New York
right I would just recruit all the sales
people from composer competitors and
wrap my office and like this startup be
[__] and go for it okay I like it
and I think what what you but I the
other part I heard that you didn't say
explicitly is just even though this
pitch didn't have everything they had
and now for you're like I need to know
more I want to know more so sometimes
you know there's better pitches on this
on this site right now but there's not
better markets and say like for example
there's this one that's about like a
rewards program for gamers
I hate this I hate this idea I hate the
market that they're in super hard to
make it work and even if they have a
great [__] even if the attraction right
now it's a stay away from me and so
whereas construction tech it's a it's a
come closer let it live flirt a little
bit more right let's get some coffee
it's like building like freakin
driverless cars right now it's like
you'll probably fail but if you make it
works like the greatest thing ever
another example is homebound you know
homebound not well okay it's launched by
atomic atomic labs or I don't know what
they call themselves atomic it's like a
start-up I don't know they just launch
companies they've launched Tim's and
they launched a few others and they're
like monkey inferno which I used to run
like a studio that that creates
companies yeah they launched one called
homebound and they're doing this but
only for people who are building
single-family homes right and it's got
some traction that's cool right I got
another company for you ready please
tell me it's the strippers on demand no
but that one's good oh we shanks talked
about that so there's this cool story
this is not a YC startup although maybe
should have been cool story we're
basically in Portland you know right now
is coronavirus everybody's getting
deliveries right and so
I have a friend who runs a company
called farmstead and they do grocery
delivery they've been doing this for you
know two years now and they all they all
farm set does is they deliver you know
your staple foods milk eggs bread stuff
you need repeatedly and you don't need
you know go to the grocery store every
time you run out of milk kind of sucks
so they just deliver to your door and so
they're like a version of instacart
that's just focused on the staples okay
and also you know for a key difference
instacart goes to the grocery store and
buy stuff and marks it up these guys are
the grocery store so they just have a
they buy wholesale and they sell retail
so they don't mark it up they actually
get good prices so ok good start up they
are exploding 20 X 30 X oversubscribed
on demand right now because everybody is
ordering food in because a coronavirus
right so everyone's getting to try this
like delivery thing they're forced to do
delivery for the first time and what
they call again those guys are called
farmstead well not farm theory ok
farmstead ok yeah this is my buddy's
company I he listens the podcast
sometime so shout-out if he's listening
so so cool name love the name yeah great
name great band it looks good that the
product is good so I actually like it a
lot now one problem that they're having
and that every delivery company is
having right now is that they're short
on drivers are short on delivery people
they have too much demand and not enough
ability to fulfill so this company in
Portland started hiring out-of-work
people from the coronavirus now what
what industry was been affected by this
strip clubs nobody's going to strip
clubs right out during coronavirus so
they hired the strippers to do delivery
and so they got a bunch of PR from this
which is a crawl I got I gotta find out
which company it was I don't know if it
was door - or whatever I don't even know
if the company really did this or the
server's just started signing up for
this that's like oh we got to make money
so what are we gonna do I guess we
should become you know delivery people
right now for the interim I see it I see
it which would do you know which company
it is that therefore does it say he
jokingly calls it Boober eats so it all
started as a joke with lucky devil
lounge one of his clubs and no one was
coming in and they go we need to do like
uber for weed delivery or Luber for sex
lube delivery and I was like let's do
Buber which is topless girl picks you up
and takes you to a strip club so anyway
that's the joke is that it's uh I don't
think it's real but it did get PR yeah
they PRI I think I think I did read that
they were like the gig workers are
basically shifting from one to another
right if you can't if the demand has
gone down in this area it's gone up and
delivery and then more people are
becoming livery drivers and it was I
thought that was interesting meals for
four-inch heels meals and 6-inch heels
well I don't know if it's smart to
create your own delivery company but I
think if you're a stripper we got to
work right now you know you girls gotta
eat got to do something well I bring up
another two I see one let's it let's see
what else okay
so ditto I think you'll like this one so
do those tagline is it's a tool for
teams to manage copy from design to
production so copy something we've
talked about I also I always define copy
because I remember when I first moved to
San Francisco got a job in tech and then
somebody asked what can be give me some
copy and I didn't know what the hell
they're talking about thought maybe they
said coffee maybe I had to go make a
copy of something I didn't know what
copywriting meant so copywriting is just
like the words on a website the words on
your on your product it's a very vague
word yeah so anyways what these guys did
was they said all right we have all
these tools like figma you know
Photoshop whatever we have Google Docs
spreadsheets so we have all these
collaborative well made SAS tools that
help us collaborate on design or on
engineering or on modeling and on in
Excel and so why is it there a tool that
helps teams collaborate on their copy
and so they basically built a tool that
says you know their their pitch which i
think is you would agree with is copy is
the most under leveraged aspect of
product building it has a higher ROI and
is easier to change than almost any
other part of your product and could
drive sales faster with better copying
which I agree with and what they're
saying is that teams don't have a great
way right now to collaborate under copy
and so they built a tool that lets you
point and click and make suggestions and
what the copy could be or should be or
look at what it was before that sort of
thing
on the product there the products not
super clear exactly what it is but I
like to know I I think it's interesting
okay but let's talk about this the the
peep okay the people who started it one
of the women
oh they're young but okay they said they
came from venture capital they were like
interns at BC so I was going to say
while they're really young their first
jobs before this for interns good for
them
so I believe their claim we think copy
will be the new visual design I think
that's I think that's true I think
design got super-important over the last
ten years and now every company just
sort of knows that paid design super
important usability UI UX is super
important and well nobody talks about
copy it's not the [__] new version of
that it always has been it just people
just are vogue in tech companies yeah
I'm at a tech company of two thousand
people I don't think I've heard the word
copy once I don't think anybody has a
strategy to make our emails better or
the text on our website battery I don't
do that though this is like saying
figmas gonna make your website look
better yeah that's true you know the
tool I think if you make it easier to do
people do do it more but right now the
problem is people aren't aware or sort
of considering this as something they
need to be focused on so yeah they need
to educate the markets of the market of
the importance of copy first and then of
having an easy tool second I think it's
cool I think it looks great there's one
red flag that I have which is they're
like the pricing it's twelve dollars a
person a month right I it's gonna be
hard to build something big when it's so
cheap you really need a lot a lot of a
lot of people right I mean they'll need
a you know a million users at that rate
they're not a million but you know a lot
maybe am well yeah a million users to be
like really large so I think their
pricing is silly but they might be able
to figure it out great idea I like the
idea but it's not there yet but
I think that if you wanted to bet on
them it's an interesting bet so here's
something interesting
have you ever read this blog post by
Stewart Butterfield called we don't sell
saddles here yeah yeah and it's old it's
old it's so Stewart Butterfield is the
founder of slack and before they
launched slack he wrote this memo to the
team and he released it later and what
he said was he wrote this blog Lowe's is
great if you're a founder you should
read this and I'll summarize it very
shortly so we don't sell saddles here
what does that mean so he talks about
let's assume you were a saddled company
you make saddles and you sell them and
so you could make saddles sell them to
existing horseback riders and basically
try to tell them why they're their old
saddle that they use is not great and
how they should be using your saddle and
that's tough because any you've got to
get people to switch and be there's just
not that many people who are horseback
riders today and here's you know the
better approach and the reason he says
we don't sell saddles here even though
we're a saddled company is that what we
need to do is sell the joy of horseback
riding if we can make people want a
horseback ride that we can tell them how
about how awesome it is to ride horses
how it's fun how it's great exercise how
it feels great to have the wind blowing
in your hair then they'll want to do it
and when they do it they'll be like oh
should I need a saddle and it's like
don't worry we got you he basically says
this is the Lululemon approach so
Lululemon doesn't go didn't go to a very
small at the time yoga industry and say
hey you should be buying hundred dollar
you know yoga pants what they did was
they helped spread the joy of the of the
sort of the lifestyle of a yoga
lifestyle they got more people that want
to do it that's why they offer yoga
classes in their store like who does
that they want people to be in that
lifestyle and then once you're in the
lifestyle it's like do you want the best
coz we we do have the best materials and
so this is just a general strategy if
you're operating in a niche sometimes
you have to actually sell the lifestyle
of being in that niche more than your
product to the existing people in the
nation I love that and did and a lot of
times not a lot of times every once in a
while those like marketing things like
and those selling the lifestyle actually
becomes bigger than the original thing
so for example this is an example where
one has become bigger but it's become
its own its own thing you know Michelin
star restaurants okay yeah you heard a
Michelin star restaurant it's like is it
it's like the standard of what is good
and why dining yeah well you know
Michelin tires created that and they did
it because they created a guide on which
restaurant like this the Michelin has
been around since this car started it
was around even before that they made
rubber for her all types of things and
then cars got popular and it was you
guys need to get out and travel the
world and you see all these amazing
things and look at these restaurants
this one we rate this one one star you
should go see it but this one's four
star you have to go see it and if you do
happen to go see it make sure that you
use our tires right are you gonna get
there you better drive if you're gonna
drive you better right and that was
that's how a Michelin star Michelin
stars got started and there's a whole
bunch of examples like that where these
marketing schemes have become their own
their own thing so anyway what's it
called again
ditto so do I think they're gonna have
to do that I think they're gonna have to
not sell saddles I think they're gonna
have to sell horseback riding and okay
so the these people who are starting it
are pretty young let's see if they're
like aggressive enough to do this and I
maybe they they might be able to but
selling copy is really easy like if I if
I like I could just go to you I could
look you give me a blank piece of paper
and because I have this skill set I'm an
ATM like you're like like if just or
like there's like this up there's this
very famous copywriting story of this
barry of this copywriter who sees a guy
who is a homeless guy who's holding a
sign and he says i'm blind please help
me and he goes and the copywriter goes
up to the guy he goes hey let me help
you out here
and he just writes it's beautiful
outside comma and then it fills in and
i'm blind please
helped interest and the whole point is
like dude if you just add two or three
words it changes everything right and so
these people did oh they're ad campaigns
could be really good so yeah good point
I'm on board can I tell a quick story
about and we're totally off the YC train
for a second but right a fun thing I
just remember when you told that story
so my very first company we had no money
we were funding the whole thing off
prize money so I would be going out like
a like a busker pitching at startup
competitions trying to win them and
every every time we won we got more
money to keep going and I don't know why
we didn't just pitch investors but like
it was working so when we just kept
doing it so we didn't have a lot of
money to hire anybody but we realized
hey we were right next to the University
of Boulder and we could get a bunch of
interns the question was how do we pick
which interns how do we know who's good
so I was like all right we're gonna
design a test case and so the case we
gave them was and we wanted a marketing
intern and I said hey you know near the
university there's a there's sort of a
homeless population and they you know
let's say today they all earn on average
50 bucks a day let's say that's what
they're making today so your challenge
to show me your marketing skills your
salve your instincts I want you to come
back and I want you to basically pitch
me a plan the idea was for them to
actually go do it but we never we never
ended up having them actually go do it
but we said come up with a plan of how
how you would earn the most money in a
given week so what would you where would
you stand so this was about like
understanding locations foot traffic
which is like essential for restaurants
so where would you pick that you were
gonna go what would you write on your
sign how would your image look what
would you what would be your sort of
your your look and why do you believe
that that would be the most effective
way to get money and this was our sort
of test as a little bit like not
politically correct but there was one
girl who had a she had a good solution
where she was like I don't remember all
the details but it was like I'm gonna go
to this area because this type of person
is she was like first I wanted to figure
out who's the type that donates and so
she was like first I would observe which
Piper person I'd spend the first day
just observing which type of person
donates and I was like that's smart
understand the customer first before you
implement your plan and then she was
like okay and then after that I'm going
to you know I would target where that
person's commute is I would be there and
then I would have a positive message
because I believe that the positive
messages will sell better than the sort
of the negative messages and I would try
to tug at people's heartstrings so I'd
go for emotion and not logic on on why
it can help but that you know I'm
struggling and I'm a mother or whatever
it is and like that's why people die so
yeah and it just proves how important
copy is and copy is not words copy is
understanding how people think and
communicating it effectively and it just
so happens it often is used with words
right
speaking of copy farm theory that is an
example of copy so you have farm theory
on here which is the selling ugly
produce to restaurants in India yes is
that a YC thing it's a YC company yes
okay no dia and that's a company in
America and what's it called you know
that it's it so it's farm theory no oh
there is also one here yeah there's a
there's like a farm-to-table box I think
that's the ugly produce thing in America
for one it's called it me too I just
googled it foods
yeah imperfect food so I'll give you the
stats on these guys so so they're doing
twenty-two thousand a month of em are
are they say forty percent profit
margins they say they're growing 65
percent week on week which doesn't mean
anything because it's YC but they're on
track to get to a million dollars a year
are the coming months what they're doing
is interesting but they're taking
farming is huge in India so they're
saying okay there's tons of farming tons
of produce produced
there's tons that's not gonna get sold
because it looks ugly it's not good for
a consumer retail but we could buy that
stuff for cheap because it's just waste
otherwise we can sell it to restaurants
who don't care about the aesthetic look
of the you know they're not picking like
a consumer doesn't in the grocery store
where they pick a you know the best
looking one out of a barrel the rustlers
don't care they're chopping it up
processing it turning into food if they
can get lower food costs fantastic
and so they're looking at you know right
now at seven hundred twenty dollars a
month just for the restaurants in
Bangalore which is a part of India and
they're they believe it's a big marker
they claim a 500 million dollar market
just in Bangalore just do the
restaurants that are there sounds a
little high to me
but the the value prop makes sense the
restaurant saves about 30% by buying
ugly produce the farm gets some revenue
out of something that would otherwise be
no revenue and they take their cut in
the middle I like it what do you think I
like it now but let me I'm always being
like the negative guy I like it but let
me tell you okay I'm a subscriber to
imperfect produce first of all it's not
imperfect like the this is a stick of
the farm theory of them selling like
things that are ugly so what do you say
they look normal you're saying yeah I
mean it doesn't look like it's a it's a
wonderful marketing scheme but it's it's
so like it's just normal [__] right
because I'm guessing you would not sign
up for something that just says here's
vegetable delivery it's like saying
there's a famous copywriter named Joe
Sugarman he wrote this great ad for a
new cast they called Cassio a Casio
watch and he's like we use space-age
aluminium with quartz movement and
[__] every watch has that same
aluminum and quartz movement is used in
nearly every single watch he just
explained it in a great way and so this
is a this is the same thing with these
guys and it's a stick that works it's a
real it's like it's like Guiness Guiness
putting a ping-pong ball in their beer I
don't know about that what is that
Guinness beer if you buy it in the can
it there's a ping-pong ball in it
because apparently that ping-pong ball
has a little bit of night as it nitric
oxide some type of like gas in there
that keeps it super fizzy I see okay and
when they release that ball it like went
up big-time I love it
yeah so this is great marketing I'm in
do it I don't know anything about India
so it's hard for me to say that
I do know that I just googled it
imperfect produce they have two hundred
thousand subscribers and wouldn't pay
per month roughly it's a weekly bill I
think I was paying two hundred dollars a
month
Wow so incredible yeah big market so
yeah III think it would depend on how
talented these entrepreneurs are but you
definitely can build something
significantly significant here right
okay give me one that you like and then
I'll be the bad guy saying wedge Ben did
we talk about up flow let's talk about
up flow okay okay I didn't know this
until well until I started my business
collections for collecting your cash
flow is actually really hard my
father-in-law has a moving business and
he's like yes to paying the but to
collect to collect the money with my
business you know we make let's say
eight figures a year and collecting the
money I used to have a team a full two
full-time people whose job it was to
collect the money now I but then I found
an outsource service to help me with it
and a lot of companies that even if
you're small let's say you only do a
million dollars a month in sales you
need someone full-time just to collect
that money and that person could be a
$70,000 a year salary person it's
expensive and so there's a lot of
services that I've recently found but
there's not that many that help you
collect money and up flow is up flow
built software where they like you can
track who owes you money based off your
QuickBooks and you can like constantly
send email reminders to those people now
the service that I use it's literally a
person who does it right and it's and
it's incredibly effective and I pay five
hundred dollars a month for it I think
and it's like easy like I would totally
I would totally like that's the last
business expense I'm gonna cut because
it was so effective so I like up flow
for that reason um let me ask you a
question when you saw this did you send
this to your finance team let's use this
yeah we saw I signed up for an account
and what was the reaction you know what
is the let's call it the friction in
adopting something like this because you
definitely have a workflow already to
collect yeah so that was the friction I
said Edie this Duke Shawn just showed me
this new company it's at YC
I signed up it looks neat if you have
any problems with our current vendor
gives these guys a look right yeah and
so the friction is that we she said she
goes yeah our people work really really
well so I don't want to disrupt it I
said yeah don't worry about it but if I
was starting again from scratch I would
maybe use these guys not a problem
the you could be you play devil's
advocate no no go for it the problem is
is that the company that I use is like
an old-school company and they have like
men and women and their 40s and 50s who
are like in Missouri who are like
pinging these people and that works it's
low tech and it's super effective the
problem that I would see what these guys
is if they try to get too techie into
Silicon Valley it could not work like
what they could do is just hire like 200
people in Missouri to just do this
manually and that could be super
effective so if I try to get cute with
the tech then it could not work and what
do you wouldn't you use the human
solution what do they take what's their
fee pay $500 a month okay so they don't
take anything on the actual collected
thing okay no but I bet you if there
might be a scale right I can tell you
what I use I think it's called ax and ax
I am oh wait no that's not it is it
Aksum
let's see let's see they could maybe
okay while you looked at it's coming to
tell you go ahead I'm gonna tell you
what I don't like about this because I'm
just trying to put my hater hat on in
general I like this idea but I'll say I
hate the way they're describing it we're
building venmo for b2b yes stupid I
don't think that's what this is and I
think that's confusing I think what they
need to say is we help businesses
collect X percent more revenue by
automating the you know collection
service today this is what happens so I
think they got cute
with this venmo for b2b and i don't
think that at all unless I'm totally
misunderstanding the product seller
saying I agree with you it is kind of
impressive they 160 paying customers and
50 50 km RR that's pretty damn good for
where they're at to be at 50 km or this
early is is actually quite impressive so
they're definitely doing something right
I don't want to hate on it just rating
on its sake I think they have a good
thing going here I don't know about the
competitive landscape and I hate the way
that they're describing I completely
agree with you I think that they're
describing it very stupidly I just sent
you the link to the service that I use
axiom ink.com ax
I am inc.com the tagline is improve cash
flow reduce risk
save money we we manage your accounts
receivable like very sit so you don't
have to worry about it and if you click
meet the team the founder his his name
is axon or no sorry James and miksa so
it's accent the good name is company's
his last name backwards and it looks
like his son or his husband some
relative is also working there and so
and it's a very like low-key
unsophisticated way to go about doing it
and it works probably doing like 30
million a year yeah and like you could
see who's collecting the money like they
have the names of the people where in
there so anyway I like this business I
just think that if you if it's if this
company of flow is run by a bunch of
young Silicon Valley guys they they have
to be careful to not overthink it and
get cute because I think I think that
like they could just do old school ways
but just package it in an interesting
way for Breck's
or for Sean's new startup or for whoever
right right right okay we'll do one more
we're almost out of time so I'll do this
company I don't know how you say tie Eve
it's ta Ivy tie em weird name
don't know why they chose that name but
whatever so what these guys are doing is
they you know how every bar or
restaurant has TVs and they're playing
sports usually or whatever it is so what
they're saying is hey the commercial
break that's a lost opportunity right so
what they do is they hijack the
commercial break on that TV and they
just upsell stuff from your menu so you
know you're watching the game when the
commercial happens it'll show the wings
that they have on the menu it'll be like
nine dollars for these wings right now
you want it it's a commercial just
locally for your bar or restaurant I
love this idea because I think there's a
lot of restaurants out there who who are
in this scenario they have you know lots
of bars lots of fresh just ahead TV so I
think there's a decent market for it
I like the idea of helping them make
money it's a very simple solution but
the thing is most these restaurants and
bars
haven't done anything yet so like this
is a lot of low-hanging fruit still
available this is one that I like it's
like sort of an ad block for those TVs
what I think might be challenging for
them is selling into bars and
restaurants I think that's gonna be a
slow and painful process for them
alright I have a little background
information on the CEO tribe TV know
what's that okay so you know the Chive
comm yep okay the tribe comm the
founders leo
it's and I know Leo and John Leo is one
of my investors and someone I look up to
he started the Chive and he now they
have chive TV and weight started was
they would get like a lot of funny
videos like America's funny some videos
looks like dad's getting hit in the nuts
by their kids swinging a pinata baseball
bat like just silly stuff and in all of
Texas what they did was they would give
these bar owners these little dongles
like these like fire sticks like an
Amazon fire stick and they uploaded all
this programming and they just like
constantly filling the pipes and so if
you go to the bar you see just like
America's Funniest Home Videos in the
background and chive would put their ads
in the in the mix and they made millions
of dollars doing it and so much so that
they eventually spun it off into a
different
company and they call it atmosphere TV
and they've just raised ten million
dollars to launch it and Leo was like
this is gonna be a multi-billion dollar
business and interesting so I have now
the verdicts still out if that's gonna
happen but chive TV was huge for the
Chive
atmosphere he says it's gonna be the
greatest thing ever and he said that
what they need to do is just go out and
hire the same thing that I described
earlier hire those people how you go
yeah we're just gonna hire a ton of
salespeople and we're gonna do this and
then another bit of background is you
and I talked to the folks at Firefly
yeah I won't put words in your mouth but
I have no problem in saying I thought
that was a horribly dumb to do good idea
and this idea is a little bit similar
but I think way better right yeah more
defensible for sure
fireflies the company that puts a little
add a little billboard thing on top of
it uber sober driver could make a little
bit more money that's cool but this is
this is a little bit different this is
more what I'll call it's not dependent
on the ad market which I like your
internally advertising stuff in the
restaurant or the bar to get people to
have a little higher check sighs yeah
but that's not what they're saying that
in their deck they say at first they're
doing what you're describing right and
they go they said all of our one-year
contracts are insanely profitable but
our next phase is to sell ad time at $25
per CPM interesting okay all right so
maybe maybe the in in restaurant upsell
is not as good as I thought and that's
why they're like already planning to go
out of that and I think that's a good
market but will in their numbers what
they're assuming they're saying they're
gonna have a $25 CPM that's gonna make
us way more money and create this new 32
billion dollar market and begin the math
is that we have X amount of impressions
and we're gonna put $25 CPM ads on there
now here's the problem which is their
fill rate is not going to be a hundred
right and it's not I'm gonna be close to
a hundred percent yeah so that's a
little ridiculous here's the other thing
I don't like so they charge forty two
hundred dollars per location per year
that's really expensive for a restaurant
or bar
they also charge a one-time $1500
hardware installation and so I just
think that they've added a lot of
friction to the adoption of this I think
already it was gonna be hard to get
people to adopt that's a high price
point and a high one-time installation
fee that they're asking people to do so
I think that's that seems tough for me
that said I think that this this could
be a business that makes 10 20 30 40 50
million dollars a year in sales this is
a great company to own not a great
company to invest not a great company if
they raised all this money that's my
opinion
yeah that make sense oh I like this they
just had someone smart once told me he's
the only thing that you can't screw up
in business is your cap table and so
when I look at when I look at a lot of
these companies I think that could be
good so salt so long as they don't screw
up their cap table right yeah that is
one way to die for the wrong reasons
that's a great way to put it
okay cool so okay we're gonna come back
and we're gonna do more of this I also
think we have be sure scheduled tomorrow
to come in and talk about buying
companies roll-ups that sort of thing
and so so we'll see how we'll see how
that cures I need to confirm with
individual but his name's Brett baby
shore at Bayshore he owns something
called permanent oh yeah I like that guy
yes he's fine then another thing that we
can do is Shawn Dave my friend Dave who
founded Soylent and also started loosie
loosie nicotine is a company you want to
he just texted me he said he wants to
come on you want him on I definitely
want him on all right I've told the
story before but I when I bumped into
him at that the hustler con after-party
we did a mini brainstorm right there and
he had you know five bangers you know
five amazing ideas just come off the top
of his head so he's the type that I look
for which is like people who've got more
ideas than time do you want me to ask
them for this Tuesday or next Thursday
yeah let's do a Tuesday all right I'll
ask him and hopefully the the people
wanted him as well okay thanks for
listening everybody stay safe share the
podcast tell your friends post on
Twitter
a little love we're trying to keep
growing this thing it's growing and we
wanted to keep growing so share it thank
you
[Music]